ce faire [ __ ] mais j'en étais sûr
c'est du micro si c'est pas vrai tout
l'art mon cul ouais poudlard my ass
j'ai un problème avec la france
les gens critiquent cyril hanouna mais
regarde son single undone je voulais
passer chez sosh french kiss c'est la
bouche
non
oh non cannibale mais tous tous pour un
mas mighty l'ag début de désir j'ai 5 %
désir faudra pas s'étonner c'est une
nouvelle jeanne d'arc qui démarque aussi
au respect tu peux sentir ma gaule
d'accord
peu de jours j'ai vu contre moi j'ai vu
un canard se prendre un panneau
j'ai rien compris
rendez vous ce soir 21 55 sur w9 pour
une émission constitué uniquement de
sketches cause des moustaches
enfin si vous regardez cette vidéo le 20
septembre parce qu'après du coup faudra
voir l'émission replay quoi je pense que
les gens avaient compris bonne n'ont
aucun argument là s'il regarde mon
argument c'est non oui mais non ce n'est
pas un argument ainsi non tu vois ah oui